did you guys post the number yes okay we
post the number we're going to the
phones again this time for trivia we're
going to be answering a series of
questions in no particular order written
by megan we don't know what the
questions are no
we most likely won't know what the
answers are yeah and we're assuming we
don't know the answers because we're all
old men and we've as as proven by the
podcast we drink too much and our brains
are deteriorating
i can't even say deteriorating i'm going
to jump into something quickly i'm
noticing all three of us are not wearing
hats i was thinking the same thing
we're not wearing why are we not wearing
hats i was thinking the same thing we
all decided not to wear hats in the same
way i thought today as i was barely
dressing myself that i was like uh i
shouldn't wear a hat i've been wearing
too many hats on the thing that's what i
that's what i was thinking i'm like what
what am i 12. there's something i was
thinking about uh on the way over here
so i i i felt in my pocket that i didn't
have any lip balm in my pocket and the
thing is is like
somehow my lips know when i don't have
lip balm in my pocket
my lips only get dry if i don't have it
in my pocket attention marine this is
lips uh i believe there's no bomb in the
pocket attention thigh fi do you notice
do you feel
uh this is lips uh uh come in thigh are
you picking up any bomb down there uh
we're sensing a no bomb scenario let us
know if no bomb is go and we will dry
the lips
that's a it's a strange thing i'm i
swear to god it it every single [ __ ]
time i don't have lip balm
you guys with your lips i don't trade
lip bumps with others that's a weird
thing to want to share with you i
appreciate it yes and then
you could wipe off that you could wipe
off the top layer that does look like it
is that is that uh caitlin's mama yeah
oh that's how things do you have in your
pockets so you have lip balm car keys
nope that's [ __ ] i got lip balm and uh
and a wallet and it's funny yeah i
always have lip la is very dry does this
go on windy does this go on glossy or
matte
it starts a little glossy than then goes
matte well oh i keep an eye out for you
guys this glossy lips where's the last
time you used this
this morning
his lips don't look glossy at all that's
great you got any cold sores i don't
think so i would either way i would wipe
it off
nice catch thanks
all right let's go to the phones let's
go to the phones
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn who is this oh my god
fellas is john crispo from dallas how's
everybody doing today
john how do you feel as though you're
gonna fare it it's always something
trivia are you a big fan you know here's
the problem here's the problem is i i
love the show watched it through all
every season maybe if you get six or
seven times the pandemic got real boring
for me but uh but i gotta say phones i
banged my head around quite a lot
playing sports growing up so i'm not
sure how much i held on to enough all
right all right all right a man after my
own heart i'm not sure about his memory
yeah john with the damaged brains let's
get to the trivia shall we if you get
three in a row without us jumping in
with a chance to steal which means you
gotta answer them fairly quickly yeah no
googling no googling then we will send
you an official signed certificate
stating that you in fact do not have
donkey brains all right let's let's
let's hear it megan let's go the first
question is from season 4 episode 1 mac
and dennis man hunters the question is
who do mac and dennis manhunt
uh
cricket
very good
what is what is rickety cricket
what
okay so that's one point to you
i'll ask a question from a fan favorite
episode season eight episode nine the
gang dines out
the question is where did dennis go down
on chrissy orlando
i i know i think i know this do i need
do i need to know whose trampoline it
was
no you do no you do not
the trampoline yeah
is doing okay okay in season three
episode 14 bum's making a mess all over
the city a mix of which band's greatest
hits is taped over by charlie when he's
undercover as serpico yeah i know oh
yeah i don't have that one search that
broken brain john
guys do you want to steal yeah i'll take
this one uh it's the spin doctors next
that is correct that's right
that is correct well it looks all right
tv show a little bit more than john of
texas yeah
texas john good talking to you buddy
love the podcast thank you for having me
on thanksgiving appreciate it
[Music]
you got donkey brains
[Music]
this is really fun writing up all this
trivia you guys was it yeah i liked it
i'm glad you like that i do too found
that
excruciatingly
see you say let's go let's go to the
phone let's go to the files
thank you for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn
hi megan oh hello all right what do we
have here hi charlie my name is john how
are you guys this is nuts hi guys john
how are you where are you calling from
john i think you're our second john
i'm calling from boca raton florida but
i live in west hollywood
yeah all right just you and a bunch of
uh retired people huh do you think you
know more about the our own tv show than
us
a little trivia i'm so excited yeah go
ahead excellent well if you get three
questions in a row correct without us
jumping in with a chance to steal which
means you have to answer them at a
fairly timely manner uh we will send you
an official certificate
signed by the three of us stating that
you in fact do not have donkey brains
the first question is from season nine
episode three the gang tries desperately
to win an award what is the name of the
signature drink at suds
which is the which is the bar that the
gang goes to i know the bar with all the
lights and the colors i have like the
really bright
oh my i have no idea guys
the name of the drink i'm a bartender
too i have no idea well the drink is
called a blue hole
it's so cool it's a massive fishbowl
[Music]
unfortunately you're not a winner today
john but uh you're a winner for making
it onto the podcast what are you doing
today what's what's happening with you
yeah what's on the docket what are you
what are you doing in raton i'm gonna
i'm really gonna hit the links no i'm
not i have no idea what i'm doing here
i'm just visiting a friend out here i
miss la but um it's nice out here it's
very sunny
oh yeah oh yeah yeah that's why so many
people go there
now is your friend an 80 year old man
no no
no but i am staying with his 65 year old
mother of course
there it is uh all right john well uh it
was great talking anybody uh thanks for
coming thank you enjoy the florida
sunshine freaking amazing i love two of
you guys
[Laughter]
sorry you lost the game get that one
there oh nice one all right hilarious
see ya john
you got donkey brains
[Music]
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn hi hello
yo what's going on yo
you know we're just sitting here doing
some trivia what's going on with you and
what's your name my name is john man
another john so many john's today are
you [ __ ] with us
[ __ ] with us right now john all right
megan let's go to the question sick
great um so this question is from season
nine episode five mac day the question
is what happens if anyone is caught
complaining on mac day i know i i know
that they're granted we're all granted
like what is it uh
one scream into a pillow yeah yeah yeah
do you know could you could you answer
um who is the first to use the screaming
pillow um is it charlie
oh no you got that wrong i believe
dennis
sorry john you just lost i believe what
yeah it's country mac that gets me
distracted
john i'm so sorry but it's been proven
today that you do in fact have donkey
brains or at the very least can't prove
that you don't yeah there's no such
certificate proving that you don't but
sean it was great talking to you and one
day you'll be the type of person who
could score a single point at a karate
tournament like very good or a single
point in uh it's always something trivia
but today you are not a single point not
a single point will be allowed to you
unfortunately have a wonderful day
[Music]
you got donkey brains
[Music]
all right what john is next megan
what's the next john through just doing
all jobs
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn
now who's calling today
alex my name is alex alex thank goodness
we've had a lot of john's it's nice to
break it up with an alex alex where are
you calling us from uh rochester new
york john john new york all right um
season seven episode six the storm of
the century what is the name of the
busty channel 5 news reporter covering
the storm
oh [ __ ]
oh is this
donna or something does it start with
the d oh you're a guy you're in the
the very the second name starts with the
d the name is jackie dinardo
oh man
oh wow
well you know how can i forget that's
the problem you were thinking
[Music]
i'm sorry alex but uh you have no such
certificate proving that you don't have
donkey brains therefore the assumption
will be moving forward that you do
indeed have donkey brains and we can't
have a donkey brain man out there
driving on the road so um so we're gonna
have to you're gonna lose your life
you're gonna lose your license yeah
sorry alex that's that's understandable
yeah that makes sense listen man it's
been a pleasure
thank you
thank you alex
[Music]
you got donkey brains
[Music]
all right here we go thank you for
calling the always sunny podcaster on
with rob charlie and glenn hello hello
hi who's going today
i'm sorry
who are you
oh i'm jeff hey hey jess where are you
calling us from
michigan
where in michigan are you from
uh jackson area got it kind of a shitty
little city oh all right all right just
from the shitty little city area of
jackson michigan
we're gonna play a little trivia today
yeah are you a big it's always sunny fan
know your trivia know your stuff i'd
like to think so okay all right so here
we go jess the first question is from
season five episode five the waitress is
getting married the question is charlie
pops an h on a box to remind him that
it's filled with what
hornets yes
there you go no hesitation no hesitation
i love it
you're gonna want to pop an h on that
box if you have a box of hornets at home
go ahead and pop an h on there yeah oh i
always do always do i'll label your
hornets all right moving right along
you're doing great um this one's from
season nine episode six the gang saves
the day
when dee saves the day in her fantasy
who does she end up marrying for 17
minutes
uh josh groban yeah yeah
she is a girl tonight of course that's
good
because i mean obviously
didn't we have like a brad pit thing
where she was like fantasizing about
brad pitt and then we like i think she
said she dumped him for groban
all right should we just award the third
point for knowing that that's pretty
mean
that is a good detail
you get this you will be the first
person to stump us
yeah and you seem very very confident
well not that we've been stopped well
you're the first person to get all the
first person yes
before we
right
jump
in
not have the brains of a donkey there's
a lot of donkey brained people out there
i hope let's see i know okay
uh this is from season 12 episode 6 hero
or hate crime
mac ends up winning the scratcher after
all of the conversation
how much is left
of the scratcher money after 17 hours
and three mediators
that's one of my favorite episodes too
yeah that's a tough one why don't we
just say
can i can i guess is it eleven dollars
close it's fourteen dollars all right
okay so wait they didn't get it right
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait hold on can can i ask a
follow-up question then if you can get
this i think that i think that she
should win okay and the question would
be how much
is the scratch-off worth to begin ten
thousand right yeah
i think she gets it
i think we've got a winner
we are noticing
a certificate proving that you're not a
donkey brain man now this is going to be
an effort
this is going to be a uh an official uh
certificate uh proving that you do not
have donkey brains that you can use in
any job interview that's right moving
forward that's right and that's
definitely going to come in handy
in the state of pennsylvania that's
right and if anyone tries to you know uh
put you in a mental institution then you
can just show that certificate and
you'll be fine you can walk around your
shitty little town waving that
certificate around and letting all those
donkey brained people know that they
cannot prove
the way that you can prove yes you don't
have donkey brains i'm proud of you
yeah you nailed it nailed it nice work
oh man thank you you're our first winner
you're the first winner no hee-haw's for
you thank you for watching the show and
thank you for not being a donkey
you don't got donkey brains
thank you for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn
hello what's up boys what's up what's
happening who's colin this is mitch from
west l.a
okay
hey mitchy mitch
big fan of the show you think you're
going to farewell at sunny trivia of
course i had your guys dvds
how old i am okay
first question is from season five
episode nine mac and dennis break up
question is when charlie and frank team
up what do they call themselves the
gruesome twosome
okay
um season four episode five mac and
charlie die part one
what is the password for the orgy
orgy yeah
all right one more mention you're gonna
have no donkey brains yeah all right
okay
i'm gonna do a slightly harder one
because you seem like you know the show
pretty well
season three episode six the gang solves
the north korea situation
mack is wearing a duster and he thinks
it makes him look like witch actor
oh good one oh
this is what you can do
real quickly
yeah
and the ladies oh no no i'm not ladies
and the ladies love it
i'm sorry mitch it's lorenzo llamas
lorenzo
i almost proved that you didn't have
donkey brains but you don't have any
such certificates
[Music]
you got donkey brains
[Music]
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast john with rob charlie and glenn
hey how's it going gang hey how is it
who's calling here yeah this is uh
patrick from louisville kentucky all
right
patrick from louisville i love it hey
patrick are you a giant fan you think
you think you know your sonny trivia i'm
a giants fan i think i know a decent bit
i'm excited to see how this goes there's
a few episodes i've seen a dozen plus
times and a few have only seen a handful
of times so excellent your first
question is from season 10 episode 8 the
gang goes on family fight
um on family fight what is charlie's
answer to the prompt name an animal we
eat that doesn't eat us a dragon oh very
good right away
i wasn't gonna let you all hop in there
on that one very good very good all
right one point one point
um
next question season two episode five
hundred dollar baby what was frank's
nickname as a boxer
uh the trash man no no wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait give me hold on
as a boxer as a boxer not a wrestler oh
the boxer oh man
oh and you guys were just talking about
this previously that's just tough
oh is it something like two left hands
or something ridiculous
[Music]
you got donkey brains
[Music]
thank you for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn who is this hi this is joe and
where are you calling from joe i'm from
long island new york oh joe from long
island hey joe hey joe we're happy to
have you on we're going to play some
trivia you ready oh that that sounds
like fun let's let's do it man okay
great all right so your first question
is from season 4 episode 8 paddy's pub
the worst bar in philadelphia so a
reporter writes a bad review about
paddy's pub d makes fun of the reporter
for ordering what type of wine
is it is it is it chardonnay yes i think
it is right yes
that is very correct okay joe that's one
point for joe you're shooting for three
you get three in a row you're a big
winner oh cool cool thanks guys okay
great um your next question season 7
episode 10 how mac got fat
dennis dyes his hair to eradicate the
grays which superhero does it make him
look like
um
well which superhero does he think it
makes yes
um
[Music]
actually he doesn't even think that yeah
they say
cool he's the original he's the original
that's right right all right okay that
was a clue that was a clue okay guys is
it is it clark kent or superman or
something something like that
we teach you up there it's superman he
was the original
okay
um
okay uh
this is a harder one because you've
gotten two right um season four episode
four max banging the waitress charlie
brings a bunch of beers over to drink
with his best friend mac how many beers
were charlie and mac planning on
drinking
um
i hear typing so help me god do not
google this all right cheers
i'm not typing i'm consistently
four three two one what's your answer uh
a whole case uh 24.
yeah joe you're our big winner uh we're
not gonna send you a car we're not gonna
send you money we're not even gonna
we're gonna send you something better
something better is coming your way
we're gonna send you a certificate
stating that you in fact do not have
donkey brains
wow guys that's that's fantastic thank
you glenn charlie and rod that and meg
thank you that's wonderful guys yeah all
right thank you so much
all right joe have a great day and uh
and congrats on on your official donkey
brainless status all right you guys have
a great day you too all right good
talking to you
very nice very sweet
you don't got donkey brains
thank you for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn hello oh my god hi hi
hi who's calling today my name's hannah
hi hannah hannah connor where are you
calling us from yeah i'm coming from
seattle washington oh yeah is it raining
of course it's raining
kind of question is that of course it's
raining
you have one of those lamps that you
have that uh make sure that you don't
kill yourself you know from depression
oh the happy lap yeah i used to but it
broke so
what the hell kind of lamp are you
talking about i want a happy lamp
if you're living in california working
the layup's not going to help but i
don't want to go outside i just want to
do it for you they just call it
medication it's a mood enhancement
okay so it's not a lamp it's a pill i'd
worry if we give you that lamp i worry
we'll never see you again
yeah you may not no but i i my office is
in the basement of my house i need some
kind of a lamp to keep me happy well do
some research and and it's called a
happy lamp yeah okay but it's recreating
the sun and we've established that you
hate the sun so i would just be
no but i i did but the happy lamp's not
gonna do the same thing that the sun
does which is just like if i want to
turn it off i can turn it i can turn the
sun off i'd like to
hannah um
how do you feel as though you're gonna
do it it's always sunny trivia are you a
big fan long time fan i love this show
so yes i i think well yeah i'm pretty
confident okay so season five episode 10
the dennis system can you tell me what
the d
in dennis system stands for
d
it was
you
do i get any hints
well i'll i'll say this if you can name
any of the stages of the dentist system
will give you this point
okay generously
would
you either google that or you got a
friend in the room
no no no tell the truth
i have my boyfriend mouthing things in
the corner
might have to change the certificate to
saying you and your boyfriend don't have
talking grants
you might have to put people on a clock
because they otherwise you have time to
google you've got time to google we
can't have time there's an honor system
happening
all right
about the boyfriend so we'll put him on
the certificate okay okay
season 11 episode 5 mac and dennis move
to the suburbs what is the name of mack
and dennis's annoying neighbor
oh my gosh
oofah
[Music]
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn it's true you are hi how's it
going how's it going who's calling us
today what's your name and where do you
live uh this is corey from sarnia
ontario canada
our first international
[Music]
are you a big fan of the show long time
fan oh i'm a huge fan i've been probably
watching always sunny for probably about
10 years now my brother was a huge fan
and got me into the show
okay so you think you're going to do
pretty well at trivia eh i think i'll do
pretty good hey all right i'll see what
i can do the first uh question is from
season 7 episode 7 charlie mcdennis the
game of games and the question is
dennis is [ __ ] why charlie hate
dennis says [ __ ] why charlie hate
um
uh is it because he
changed the rules or because he meant no
it's because he melted his
glenn can you perform it the way that
you cause dinners is a bastard man yeah
because dennis is a bastard man
oh we cannot send you a certificate you
will not be able to prove that you don't
have the brains of a donkey
honestly i can't believe i just made it
on here that that was a win in itself
that is a win in it of itself aren't you
[Music]
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn who do we have here let me guess
john
holy [ __ ] i got on no it's stephen
stephen where are you calling us from uh
the doctor's office i just sat
i think i need more alcohol as the
solution
what is going do you tell us the truth
doubtful stephen what is the problem
yeah what's going on is this just a
general thing i have a mild allergy
allergy to aspirin actually
doing a follow-up you don't need to go
to the doctor for that just don't take
aspirin
well he's doing a follow-up to see if
he's got the aspirin out of his system
come on it can't be that bad
but i've got the first trivia question
i've got the first trivia oh you're
gonna ask me you're gonna ask me we're
gonna ask you three questions okay uh
okay the nurse just came in so she's
going to be here with me
all
right
speaker let's talk to the nurse okay
that's fine um are we on speaker okay
we're on speaker now okay
hey how's it going john's on a radio
show he's doing trivia and uh we're
going to try to get these answers in
before he passes
so um
so actually now that we have the nurse
on the line
nurse can we ask you your name
where is this uh it's always sunny
podcast so it's rob mac and charlie from
tv
no i'm not going to get my name
by the way totally
highly professional
and i would advise uh as your attorney
to do the same yeah um but uh have you
seen our the television show
no what's your call always send me to
philadelphia oh yeah yeah okay
all right that's fun okay let's ask us
let's
his trivia questions maybe we should ask
the nurse a question assuming that what
but something rather easy like who is on
who is the most famous person on the
show let's just say um
who is the most i think we all know the
answer fair to stephen who's called from
the doctor he's just trying to have fun
yeah steven doesn't have time for this
and neither does the nurse okay great
let's just go back okay shenanigans all
right um this question is from season
one episode four charlie has cancer what
is dennis coming over to borrow when he
finds out charlie might have cancer well
it could be a number of things but if i
remember correctly it was sugar
wow okay that's really interesting
that's a very fair what's interesting is
that sugar was our original home movie
the thing that aired in the episode was
he was coming over for a basketball yeah
i think he would give him credit i think
we got it
stephen i think you get the point
because it's a deep
cut yeah
[Music]
your renamed from jack bauer
[Music]
jack bauer agent jack bauer but jack
bauer counts i think that's right
okay stephen you're on your way you're
on your way
season five episode eight paddy's pub
home of the original kitten mittens um
inspired by charlie's kitten mittens
idea what do dennis and mack come up
with to advertise the bar you can either
thing they come up with
things but i believe it was a shotgun or
a gun shot
steven is a big fan in addition to that
there's the paddy's thong yeah yeah why
is steven gonna win stephen we are going
to send you a certificate stating that
you in fact do not have donkey brains
this will be an official certificate
you can show it every time you show up
to a job interview or the doctor's
office it is legal and binding and uh
good luck uh at the doctor's office and
stay away from aspirin it doesn't it
doesn't treat you well
you don't got donkey brains
thanks for calling the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn who do we have on the line this is
gabriel
where are you calling us from
hey uh texas actually south texas all
right
gabriel are you a long time sunny fan
you think you're going to do well at
trivia i hope so man i've been listening
since i was 18. i'm 35 now so i love it
rob's got a question for you since
you're from texas uh yes gabriel do you
have uh the state of texas uh or the
longhorn somewhere tattooed on your body
unfortunately i do not but my girlfriend
does there you go okay there you go you
say it was about a fifty fifty fifty
chances
does she have a long horn does she have
a state flag what does she got there
it's a this is the shape of texas so she
protection and then does she have like a
little uh like a little circle into what
part of this of the state she lives in
or is from a dot maybe never seen that
before no i believe it's uh it's uh the
the state and then it's like the flag of
texas yeah
i can't believe i'm talking to you guys
this is insane
i can't believe you're talking to us
either all right gabriel your first
question is from season three episode
two the gang gets invincible what is the
name of dee's male alter ego
dresses up like a man what is that man's
name
hmm
that's a tough one i gotta say well we
just watched this
yeah if we hadn't re-watched that one i
don't think i would have known it but we
did mention it in the podcast so maybe
you're not really listening to the
podcast oh gabriel you're kind of a
double you're gonna get docked you're
gonna get docked for that so the answer
is correct
yeah is that ringing a bell now yeah
yeah now it is but
i can feel the disappointment in your
voice thanks for calling in and it makes
me sad because i like it i like you
okay if you'd like we can send you
nothing to your local tattooist uh to
get the state of texas on you somewhere
um
yeah but uh we're not going to no no no
no no no we're gonna have to do that we
recommend
oh man gabriel thanks for calling in
thanks for being a uh you know small
part of our lives
[Music]
you got donkey brains
[Music]
thanks for calling the always honey
podcast you're on with rob charlie and
glenn who is this
oh my god this is katie from south
philly
katie
um i'm at 10th and daley
like a little north of oregon all right
all right all right rob knows that they
are near the oregon diner right there by
the organization have you met rob before
yeah have we met
we have not met okay okay i don't think
so i think i would have remembered
you're probably yeah i'm guessing you're
20 years younger than that than rob
aren't you time i left the city of
philadelphia you were not born yeah rob
lives in a big mansion in los angeles
now he's not in south philly anymore uh
where
where did you go to school where to high
school did you go to
i went to morristown high school in new
jersey
all right
well
let's hope you're good at trivia because
if you get three questions in a row
correct we're going to send you a
certificate stating you in fact do not
have donkey brains well i love that and
i have one sonny trivia in south philly
in she's a before
ask her something more difficult yeah
we're going to come at you hard katie
we're going to come at you hard now all
right katie how many reggie how many
reggie leech books have you guys gotten
so far wow
wow reggie leach okay wait a second that
might stump these guys here
do you know who reggie leach is i know
his brother robin and he he uh he had
that show about the rich and famous yes
reggie
he's played a role in our sh
[Music]
it was the episode where it was the
answer that you answered correctly
and you got to go take the slap shot
yeah
thank you max
big break by the way you know those the
the the picture of the two guy flyer
guys that we have they're not flyers
oh that that one yes you know how the
yeah so go ahead go ahead i i met that
guy
like on the set of like
good morning america he was like working
he's like hey man that's me in the
picture that's crazy yeah in your bar
that's amazing yeah wow lovely gentlemen
that's pretty cool all right let's get
to the questions okay katie your first
question is from season 9 episode 7 the
gang gets quarantined to appeal to
sympathies d is going to play a southern
army vet whose father died of throat
cancer after eating what
some bad [ __ ] yeah
that was crazy
it was the adding of the bad yeah yeah
it had gone bad it turned
oh yeah i think just just saying [ __ ]
alone would not have been acceptable
like that's not going to give you it was
the bad boy
that had had turned it it had gone bad
but
[Music]
all right this is uh you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to dig deeper here
i'm trying to find something
for speaking we have a professional on
our hands so your hands are sweating
all right my hands are they are a little
sweaty but i said that they're shaking
oh they're shaking okay
that's all right you don't need steady
hands
yeah okay
okay your next question is from season
12 episode 8 the gang tens bar and the
question is what is the name of frank's
tapeworm jerry yeah
i don't think this is the donkey brain
person this
is not a donkey brain person i don't
think so no okay after she wins
answering whatever this one is you maybe
katie you should ask us one yeah
she's gonna stop buzzfeed i think she
should i think that's a good idea okay
great you think of that and i'm gonna
give you your last question here which
is season four episode six mac and
charlie die part two
dennis gets a new european roommate what
is his name
oh
you might have stumped me guys
it's oh no
and i'm also tiptoeing the line of like
trying not to be racist
so you're all right there
europe is not a race
yeah i believe i believe we established
that he is european and that's it and
that's yeah that's it and i think his
yeah his accent was just vaguely
european european yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it is giving that ambiguous european
vibe
guys i've never been what was it what
was the answer i'm so sorry katie but
the answer is yawn
yeah wow that's surprising now listen
get that one now because you got deep
cuts like jerry and uh whatever we have
i think we should give her one more shot
i think we should give her a chance to
stump us she stumps up okay you stump us
you stop by you get the point you get
that third point you get a certificate
three stops
does she have to stump us three times or
just just once
okay all right one stop
can i just make a quick request that rob
i don't think rob should answer should
be allowed to answer this one
okay
okay
okay well how about this if because it's
probably failure related if the guys
can't answer it and they get stumped you
get the certificate if i too am stumped
we're gonna send you a case of carmine
stakes
[Music]
i have a feeling she's about is this
going to be sunny trivia or just trivia
in general
this is sunny trivia okay great okay
okay
but why is it that you think that it's
because it's gonna be fully related it's
gonna be fully related
i won't be able to recall the season or
episode but when charlie bets the bar on
the dance marathon contest what radio
station uh
does he sign up with yes
oh you will not have stumped me uh uh uh
like what are the callers yeah yeah
it's it's a it's cute cue something
oh god damn it what is it oh oh [ __ ]
wait
the q crew i remember it's the q crew
crew i'm already impressed wkrq
no [ __ ]
you are stumped but it is q 102. 102.
you know what uh katie
i think that we're going to have to send
you a certificate a signed certificate
stating that you do not in fact have
donkey brains because it seems to me
like you don't i don't think you do and
i tell you what katie i couldn't
remember yawn so
like
it wasn't a clean sweep on our end i
didn't i i did not and the only reason i
remember q102 is because q102 is a real
radio station
uh
congratulations
great work you don't have thank
so very much thank you that certificate
oh go sorry go ahead go ahead
i just love sunny i love you guys i've
always heard like don't meet your idols
but that's both it because you guys are
[ __ ] awesome and i can't believe i
got to spend this stay with you i
ignored a call from my boss i was on
hold
off
thank you that feels so nice you've been
awesome too it's nice to know someone
loves the show and knows so much about
it yeah yeah thanks katie congrats megan
you're awesome i love your laugh oh
thanks katie she does have a great we do
too have a great laugh
all right laughs
thanks for calling in katie appreciate
it
you don't got donkey brains do you want
me to
ask you the heart like a really hard one
oh yeah yeah let's do that yeah let's do
that
yeah ask us some really hard top it off
with a little self trivia yeah okay wait
wait wait wait we should we should do a
thing where like we
who either blurt out the answer like we
have to whoever answers first gets
a point are we all on the same team why
don't we just how about instead of
making competitive we're all on the same
team
but you want to make it
okay let's let's do that first and see
how it goes okay season four episode
seven who pooped the bed name the items
found in the poop
a wolf hair credit card we'll pair some
shredded credit card
there's two more things there's one more
thing
there was blood i know there's a hair
credit card uh pocket lint pocket no no
no no no
sweater no no no no
no uh cat litter no no
newspaper oh newspaper [ __ ]
wolf hair was the only thing well there
was a wolf there
inconclusively yeah
all of those things have been like that
has to be one of you specifically it's
like
it could be either one of the ways
we both bit the wolf
all right how about season six episode
one mac
fights gay marriage where did charlie
find the almonds he feeds to the gang
ally
yeah you found him in the end yeah
there were alliances
yeah um
according to the game charlie mcdennis
what is the greatest band in the world
what episode did i i found something in
a pipe it was like the snake it could
have been a snake egg oh yeah yeah
it was an egg but you didn't know what
it was you didn't know if it was a snake
or a bird yeah because it was in a pipe
here's one what's the name uh in season
eight episode eight charlie rules the
world what is dee's screen name in the
online game she's playing uh queen of
thrones
swingin uh swingin cutie yeah or
something cutie yeah yeah yeah uh twenty
or something swinging
20 something yeah yeah
the 29 was the representer h
yeah 23. 23. was it swinging cutie yeah
in season 9 episode 9 the gang makes
lethal weapon six what instrument does
the remaining twin use to blow up the
wedding
wait wait wait can you see that again oh
jello
yes that's right
got a big antenna on it
i mean the [ __ ] joke was obvious but
bad [ __ ] had forgotten the specific
yeah i know i've said this a million
times but that i think is my one of my
favorite moments i i think maybe my
favorite performance moment on the
entire in the entire show is her
performance of that that particular
moment yeah that's very good it is just
it just kills me it kills me
what else you got anymore good uh sure
um
what uh season five episode five the
waitress is getting married what is the
name of the waitress's fiancee
rad brad fisher brad fisher very good
you guys are great at this let's do one
final trivia question okay one for the
room
all right your deepest track your
deepest cut um
season seven episode three frank
reynolds little beauties what is the
name of dee's rival in the beauty
pageant
okay
ooh
okay the popular pretty girl yep yep yep
yeah oh man
hmm damn it it's not brianna no oh god
i can't i don't know it's the it's yeah
the
the the younger sister right that that
she's competing
the pretty one yeah
who like does end up winning the one who
wins yeah the one who wins
she's the prettiest
she's i love that i think you're like
well she's the prettiest
uh damn it what was her name
um
yeah well you said you just said brianna
and like oh i [ __ ] you up yeah i'm
sorry but you gotta get that stuck in
your hand
no
it's not britney
no [ __ ] what is it samantha
[Music]
[Applause]